the wait is over the HBO Go app for Xbox
one has arrived every episode of every
season of your favorite HBO shows are
now available that means you can watch
the latest episodes from shows like true
detective Game of Thrones and girls
along with your favorite hits like
Entourage and The Sopranos with HBO GO
and Xbox one you get unlimited access to
HBO original series hit movies sports
documentaries and comedy specials and
more in HD once your account has been
activated you can search through what
HBO GO has to offer using different
categories like movies series comedy
sports documentaries and others found on
the left side here select a series like
Game of Thrones then select an episode
you want to watch you'll see an episode
description and you can also view
behind-the-scenes videos recaps sneak
peeks and learn more details about the
cast & crew by clicking on extras & info
if you're itching to watch a movie you
can search for whatever strikes your
fancy alphabetically or by genre such as
drama action suspense and just added
last but not least one of my favorite
features is the ability to pin HBO GO or
specific content to your home screen now
this is awesome because I can pin the
true detective series and pick up right
where I left off with less than three
clicks
and there you go the HBO Go app on Xbox
one available today I'm Larry herb Xbox
Live's Major Nelson thanks for watching